it must stop
when rodrigo duterte won the
presidential election in 2016
he promised to bring unprecedented
change to the philippines
by ending corruption within his first
six months in office
but as he enters the final year of his
term duterte's administration
is being bombarded by allegations of
plunder
and abuse of power government contracts
amounting to billions of pesos
opposition leader sonny celianes has
revealed government documents
that show how a longtime duterte aids
family
has acquired hundreds of million dollars
worth of contracts
in the southern region of davao where
duterte was a city mayor
for more than 20 years
and even senator manny pacquiao the
world renowned
boxer who has long been one of duterte's
strongest
supporters says corruption in the
government
is rampant duterte says the allegations
aren't true and politically motivated
pacquiao is
punch drunk he is punch drunk
pacquiao is punched drunk does he think
my own cabinet will allow theft in
billions
but since 2017 there have been
corruption scandals involving duterte
appointed officials
and even members of his own family
president duterte once said that just a
whiff of corruption
will be enough for him to fire
government officials
but many of those who have been removed
from office have yet to face charges
and over the last two years duterte has
also refused to reveal his wealth
to the public by not releasing his
latest statement of assets
liabilities and net worth the first
president
to ever do so in decades analysts say
duterte's track record
in fighting corruption lacks conviction
look at the ruling coalition of the
president it's it's a
big ten coalition that effectively uh
you know takes into uh its embrace
all sorts of people including warlords
including
uh you know traditional politicians
all these political dynasties dominating
the country
but despite all of this duterte's
popularity among filipinos
remains high and many wonder whether
that means he still has time
and support to implement reforms that
will form part
of his legacy jamal alindogan al jazeera
manila